today's topic homophobic tweets by Kevin
Hart everybody's heard about the Kevin
Hart scandal he made some tweets that
were homophobic and then they got them
he had to step down from doing hosting
the Oscars now we were gonna cover this
story but it's been a recent update that
we find very interesting
Nick Cannon has decided to come out of
the woodwork and be like yo y'all think
what Kevin said was anti-gay look at
what these female comics say and I
haven't read these tweets yet so we're
gonna leave right we're gonna read them
live on this reactor Shafi handler this
is what a fat bird likes when he flexes
use the word [ __ ] cool [ __ ] bird sir
Superman I don't mean this in a hateful
way you know you're gonna do the
opposite yeah you know you're gonna do
the exact opposite I don't need to be
racist [ __ ] [ __ ] you know let's go
I'm touching my nipples right now
generating anticipation let's go I don't
mean this in a hateful way but the new
bachelorettes is a [ __ ] Amy Schumer
enjoy Skyfall [ __ ] about to get me deep
in the hunt
so yes obviously is our double stand in
this case yes people should dig our
digging up the tweets of whole bunch of
dudes trying to get them to feel guilty
about what they've done or what they've
said 1020 years ago here's a reality all
of our views have progressed over time
words are things that I thought were
acceptable in the past I no longer think
are acceptable and to judge someone for
things they may have said 20 years ago
in the context of when it was
potentially acceptable or more so it's
unfair it is simply on fair and we have
to keep that in mind because if we hold
everyone to that standard then it's just
not really we have to also remember
celebrities are people as well right and
we want them to be more real we more
authentic and when they misspeak
we-we-we-we chastised them real quick
for not being perfect for not using the
proper speech when we ourselves are
guilty of the exact same sins we just
don't have the platform for people mind
you we look at everybody I know for
myself when I'm going to get to a
certain spot those are the people who
will comb through my pass on they're
gonna find something am I going to
apologize for it it'll be based on that
specific instance but I do think we've
gone very far and always
trying to engage in these witch hunts to
look for demons that no longer exist
today but we still want to make people
apologize for them apologize you already
possess that is reality it's too late to
apologize Kevin took his stand said now
I already apologized miss in the past
nothing apologize for it again that joke
was wack and I'm not gonna do it today
but how forty said sorry and he said I'm
not on podcast he stepped down from the
Oscars and the new come on keV stand on
your principles you do want to apologize
you didn't just did it cuz there's mad
pressure and you gotta make your chair
all right you already step down yo you
step down finally when you guys see you
grabbing your balls you like nah let me
drop them again that's like come on bro
how much did every one of you should
look at your memories on Facebook and
look at that dumb [ __ ] there is nothing
more crazy when Facebook is like we have
a notification where you check out your
memories and then you see nine years ago
hey Serena
I'm waiting in front of your place you
have an answer to three hours it's just
like I look [ __ ] lame and she got
notifications of she's reminded and I'm
mad know every year not Facebook Lord
[ __ ] get rid of this [ __ ] cringe - I
want us to as decide to scale it back
and just to breathe a little bit yeah
that tweet in a vacuum is terrible when
nothing happens in a vacuum in our world
today we all live in a world with
context and culture you always have to
look at that he already apologized why
make him apologize again since we go I
think it's a power trip to me the reason
why I didn't want him to apologize in
truth cuz it's a power trip it's people
trying to you know put their sense of
morality on others and then showcase
that if you go against what we think am
I giving her me he should be near me I'm
gonna bring desi well you remember when
he didn't man instead of us having a
discussion that can lead to something
more more positive what we have is we
have someone apologizing and then we're
trying to move on nothing was discussed
this will repeat itself because we're
not
have the more difficult top which is are
our views changed on homosexuality how
can we improve what are things that we
do instead of having Kevin Hart become
an ally in this discussion what you've
done is you've crossed your signs them
you've authorized a whole bunch of
people who feel like you're out for a
paragraph and now nothing is going to
improve from this whole thing its
comment with racist issues you know I
want to draw apologize she says I'm
racist I don't care if she apologizes I
don't care if someone who said something
terribly racist apologize that's not
what I'm looking for needs to understand
why our society views blackness this way
what we can do to improve it because we
had a million apologies and we still
where we at today so until we have a
very difficult talk about these
difficult topics we're not going
anywhere
people tell me I apologize Rachel I
refuse I will not apologize for it
unless I actually thought I was wrong
what I'm trying to get is that instead
of us having a difficult talk about you
know humor and we're a can or can't go
instead of us having to talk about you
know can men have these talks about rape
you know we're all we're doing is
apologize apologize I'll remove it and
if I don't understand how the foot will
happen without having this conversation
simple those who don't learn from
history are doomed to repeat it and
y'all better keep the same [ __ ] image
yeah keep the same in our school because
if you condemn Kevin for the comments
that he made if I see Sarah Silverman at
any [ __ ] profaneness rally and she
has an apologized 100 times
[ __ ] I'll be here three minutes walk
outta here leave this a minute and
people are going to say men are trash
but y'all some goddamn hypocrites and